et à tous sont des personnes présentes
chers collègues
toujours dans le cadre de la commission
d'enquête sur Tik Tok nous avons le
plaisir d'auditionner ce matin Monsieur
Benoît Loutrel ancien directeur général
de l'Autorité de régulation des
communications électroniques des postes
et de la distribution de la presse la
recette ancien directeur chargé des
relations institutionnelles de Google
France c'est un aspect intéressant sur
ce qu'on traite également et aujourd'hui
conseiller membre du collège de
l'Autorité de régulation de la
communication audiovisuelle et numérique
l'art comme
autorité publique indépendante qui
résulte comme on sait de la fusion au
1er janvier 2022 du CSA et de la Haute
autorité pour la diffusion des oeuvres
et la protection des droits sur Internet
la doPi l'arcom est notamment compétente
en matière de régulation des plateformes
en ligne et des réseaux sociaux ces
compétences sont progressivement été
renforcées par les lois récentes
relatives à la protection de l'enfance
et de l'adolescence à la manipulation de
l'information à la lutte contre la
diffusion de fausses informations et la
haine en ligne autant d'enjeux pour
lesquels nous souhaiterions connaître
les risques spécifiques de votre point
de vue pour les utilisateurs de Tik Tok
selon la presse vous avez même reçu
cette semaine le Conseil Général de by
dance à propos des critiques exprimées
par l'arcome sur la faible qualité du
rapport sur la lutte contre la
désinformation remis par Tic-Toc l'an
dernier vous exprimerez sans doute sur
ce point également en tout cas c'est
point sur lequel on souhaiterait vous
entendre je rappelle que cette audition
est captée et retransmise en direct sur
le site Sénat et avant de vous laisser
la parole pour un exposé luminaire d'une
quinzaine de minutes si vous aviez prévu
des choses ainsi je vais procéder au
formalité d'usage pour les commissions
d'enquête je dois ainsi vous rappeler
qu'un faux témoignage devant notre
commission d'enquête et passible des
peines prévues aux articles 434 très 434
14 et 434 15 du code pénal je vous
invite à prêter serment de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité en levant la
main droite et en disant simplement je
le jure merci Monsieur Loutrel vous avez
donc la parole pour l'exposé imminaire
après quoi Monsieur le Rapporteur
ouvrira le bal des questions j'en aurai
bien une probablement et qu'on puisse
tourner près de l'ensemble des collègues
et avoir un échange éclairant pour la
Commission et pour tous ceux qui nous
écoutent
faux départ merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
je aujourd'hui je souhaitais partager
effectivement en réponse à vos questions
d'expérience qui est celle de la com
vous l'avez rappelez depuis maintenant
2018 avec le vote de la loi sur la lutte
contre un manipulation de la formation
l'arcom est en plus de ces munitions
traditionnelles de régulateur
audiovisuel devenu aussi un régulateur
de ces nouvelles plateformes numériques
de partage de contenu qui à la fois ou
un succès fulgurant et à la fois par les
débordements qui les accompagnent
questionnent le fonctionnement de nos
démocraties
nous avons eu l'occasion comme vous
l'avez mentionné
communiquer en novembre dernier en
faisant le point sur la mise en oeuvre
de la loi manipulation de la formation à
la fois de tout acquis qui était le
nôtre de mettre en oeuvre ses lois
françaises et à la fois pointé limite et
spécifiquement épinglé la société Tik
Tok nous avons effectivement depuis 2018
avec cette loi lutte contre un
manipulation d'information une dynamique
en France très forte ou le législateur
en créant ce devoir de coopération des
grandes plateformes et de voir de
participer à la lutte contre un
manipulation d'information a permis de
créer une dynamique qui a fait que nous
avons une sentiment d'être mieux armé
pour faire face aux risques informations
étrangère le cas échéant dans les
processus électoraux c'était l'objectif
de cette loi et nous avons vu à quel
point le fait d'avoir une autorité
publique qui soit désignée pour servir
de points de coordination avait de la
valeur a permis aux plateformes de
s'engager de mieux se préparer à
l'élection présidentielle on a pu en
anticipation les préparer à la mise en
place la base de la commission
électorale qui a suivi l'élection
présidentielle à travailler aussi à
échanger avec le Conseil constitutionnel
pour avoir une mobilisation de toutes
les plateformes et des pouvoirs publics
sous l'égide des autorités en charge du
suivi d'élection et pour être mieux à la
même de faire face éventuellement un
trouble informationnel alors il n'a pas
eu lieu la menace ne s'est pas
concrétisée on permettrait cette formule
et une diversion tragique à l'est de
l'Europe qui a sans doute expliqué cela
mais on a le sentiment à ce moment-là
qu'on était beaucoup mieux préparé alors
on a enchaîné cet exercice aussi la loi
exige que les plateformes s'engagent
dans la lutte contre un manipulation de
la formation prennent des mesures
proactives et c'est crucial les rangs
transparentes non pas les partages avec
le régulateur mais les rendre
transparentes c'est-à-dire que les tout
le monde puisse en prendre connaissance
que tout le monde puisse participer à
comprendre ce que font les plateformes
parce que on souhaite à la fois et
c'était la sagesse du régulateur
qu'elles agissent mais que tout le monde
comprenne et que à la fin on renforce
bien la confiance
on a fait cet exercice et pour la
première fois il s'appliquait à Tik Tok
dans les années précédentes il ne
s'appliquait pas à Tik Tok parce que
l'entreprise n'avait pas franchi les
seuils qui la soumettait à cette
obligation donc pour Tik Tok à sa
décharge c'est la première fois que la
plateforme était soumise à cet exercice
mais nous avons dû constater que pour
l'ensemble des plateformes on commençait
à atteindre les limites du système ou
trop de nos questions avaient des
réponses incomplètes et des réponses ou
simplement pas de réponse mais qu'en
plus pour Tik Tok c'était poussé à un
niveau qui était plus fort et c'est pour
ça on les a publiquement épinglé je cite
quelques termes qu'on a mis dans les
documents qu'on rend public parce que on
dit les choses la déclaration est
particulièrement imprécise avec peu
d'informations relatives au service en
France aucun élément tangible permettant
une évaluation des moyens mis en place
disputif de signalement accessible mais
peu visible accessible il y a une icône
en forme de flèche
symbolisant le repartage du contenu
développement en 2022 d'une politique
dédiée aux médias contrôlée par un état
alors ça c'était un point positif en soi
de dire effectivement parfois il faut
savoir aider les usagers une plateforme
à faire à différence en disant mais qui
publie une information éventuellement
être information en disant attention
cette information est publiée par un
MEDAC qui est contrôlée par un État qui
peut avoir une certaine visée et TikTok
mettait ça en avant comme un point
positif et en signalant qu'ils avaient
effectivement étiqueté les chaînes
ukrainiennes qui étaient contrelées par
l'État ukrainien dans une situation de
guerre pour mettre en garde en disant
mais interrogez-vous est-ce que l'État
ukrainien a un intérêt à pousser une
certaine information et à notre grande
surprise on a dû constater que les
chaînes Tik Tok
cgtn China global TV John Network qui
est une chaîne d'État chinoise n'avait
pas été étiqueté par tictoc comme une
chaîne d'État et donc ça résume aussi
une des difficultés qu'on avait c'est
que on sent que cette entreprise non
seulement n'a pas répondu pleinement à
la questionnaire mais surtout est encore
dans un processus très jeune de
construction de sa politique de
modération de documentation de sa
politique de modération et de mise en
oeuvre cohérente de sa politique de
modération et ce genre de d'imprécision
clairement nous poser problème et on a
souhaité le rendre public
démonstration aussi que le fait de
soumettre une entreprise à une
transparence à la valeur l'entreprise
est revenue vers nous très vite nous
avons corrigé cette erreur vous pouvez
aller sur Tik Tok et vous pourrez
constater que les chaînes chinoises
comme China global TV vision network
sont maintenant
identifiés de la même manière avec un
avertissement attention c'est un média
qui est contrôlé par le gouvernement
chinois faites preuve de sens critique
le
d'une manière plus globale aussi
nous sentons que cette entreprise où est
sa spécificité pour reprendre aussi
rejoint la les éléments que vous avez
mis en avant dans la création de cette
commission d'enquête
elle est très jeune elle a eu un succès
fulgurant et son succès commercial n'a
pas été accompagné du même engagement à
construire les mécanismes de
responsabilité toutes ces entreprises
ces plateformes développent une activité
dite de Trust en safety de confiance et
de sécurité c'est-à-dire les services de
l'entreprise qui veillent à l'intégrité
de la plateforme qui vaille à ce qu'il
n'y ait pas de troubles sur la
plateforme que les
usagers de la plateforme ne soient pas
en danger c'est une activité qui
historiquement dans ces plateformes
c'est développé de manière volontaire
chez TiK ToK on sent que elle n'a pas
ils n'ont pas mis autant d'énergie à
développer ses activités au fur et à
mesure de leur croissance commerciale
le
l'exercice que nous a emmené en novembre
à montrer toute la valeur de travailler
avec les lois françaises et ces lois et
aussi montrer les limites les limites
qu'on a pu mettre en évidence c'est
qu'effectivement on n'avait pas une
capacité à exiger cette transparence et
on était parce que c'était des premières
lois et la France a voté ses lois en
2018 l'Allemagne a voté une loi en 2019
qui était la loi nets des gay sur Naïn
en ligne la France a revoté une loi
serait une en ligne qui a été
globalement invalidé par le Conseil
constitutionnel mais qui a mis en place
un observatoire des plateformes qui a
prouvé sa valeur comme étant un enceinte
de discussion avec toutes les parties
prenantes et qui avait créé un parquet
national de Anne en ligne qui a beaucoup
de valeur lui aussi et
nous on a conclu en disant notre
exercice en novembre
nous avons un énorme acquis grâce à ses
lois nous avons développé un
savoir-faire une capacité
institutionnelle une dynamique et
maintenant on est prêt à être plus
ambitieux et depuis aussi
nous avons maintenant la perspective de
mettre en oeuvre le cadre européen qui
vient répondre à ses attentes
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut avoir conscience
que les lois françaises les lois
allemandes ont servi à organiser la
montée en compétences des pouvoirs
publics des législateurs des régulateurs
des gouvernements pour savoir comment se
saisir vraiment encore plus globalement
de ces sujets de ces problématiques et
depuis nous sommes en train de basculer
dans cette logique de préfiguration de
la mise en oeuvre du Règlement sur les
services numériques qui va permettre
d'aller beaucoup plus loin dans la mise
en oeuvre
d'une exigence de responsabilité des
très grandes plateformes et de Tik Tok
en particulier le
ce qui va changer en allant de l'avant
c'est qu'effectivement
toute cette activité dite de
sécurisation de la plateforme
d'intégrité de la plateforme de trust
and safety cela relevait avant de la
bonne gestion de l'entreprise de
quasiment de l'engagement social RSE de
l'entreprise
aujourd'hui avec le cadre européen qui
se déploie c'est une exigence légale et
vous avez tout un réseau de régulateur
et un réseau de pouvoirs publics qui se
mobilise et dont le premier objet et en
fait de permettre à tout le monde de
participer à cet exercice de
responsabilité
parce que ce qu'on voit sur les réseaux
sociaux que ça soit
la haine en ligne que ça soit la mise en
danger des publics ça peut être les
mineurs ça peut être simplement
le fait que l'usage de ces plateformes
renforce des addictions
provoque des problèmes de santé publique
d'obésité
c'est le problématique de tout le monde
et ça n'est pas la problématique du
régulateur et donc la fonction de
régulation qui est créée dans le cadre
européen est fondamentalement une
fonction qui vise à permettre à tout le
monde de se saisir de ces sujets
pour permettre
d'agir collectivement et non seulement
pour mobiliser mais aussi pour garder la
confiance parce que on est au coeur du
fonctionnement démocratique de nos
sociétés et ces plateformes sont à la
fois des lieux dans lequel on a
étendu énormément notre capacité à
exercer notre liberté d'expression
et c'est ça qui fonde aussi leur succès
populaire et à la fois
ces nouvelles libertés appellent de
nouvelles responsabilités donc ce cadre
européen est fait pour renforcer très
sensiblement la responsabilisation des
grandes plateformes numériques et pour
aussi permettre la mobilisation pour
créer une meilleure sentiment de
responsabilité des usagers qui font tout
aussi partie de la solution et du
problème et c'est tout l'enjeu de
construire des citoyennetés numériques
un sentiment de citoyenneté numérique
voilà ce que je peux dire peut-être en
introduction et je suis à disposition
pour poursuivre la discussion
en répondant s'il y a des éléments je
pense qu'à l'occasion des questions ça
vous permettra de préciser monsieur le
rapporteur
merci beaucoup
merci d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation et de passer
quelques moments avec nous et merci pour
votre exposé préliminaire alors je
voulais
le locataire général de notre commission
a envoyé après lament à cette réunion un
questionnaire
détaillé parce que leur comme c'est pas
c'est pas n'importe quel organisme
c'est-à-dire la régulation ça implique
beaucoup beaucoup de sujets y compris
beaucoup de sujets qui vont jusque dans
les détails et donc il est difficile en
une heure ou une un peu plus de
commissions de bouger toutes ces
questions donc nous avons envoyé à
Monsieur Loutrel à des questionnaires
détaillés et on va continuer ce dialogue
après la réunion en fonction notamment
des réponses que vous que vous nous
apporterez pour vraiment avoir une une
vision détaillée de l'ensemble des
rapports actuellement qui sont ceux
entre de l'arcom avec avec Tik Tok alors
avant que les autres
sénateurs posent un certain nombre de
questions moi j'en ai pour ma part
quelques unes
qui fait d'ailleurs de référence
l'introduction que vous avez faite il y
a un instant et notamment au début de
votre discours vous avez rappelé que
l'arcom a fait un rapport le 18 novembre
2022 et ce rapport était sur toutes les
plateformes bien entendu mais il était
particulièrement
critique à l'égard de Tik Tok pour la
raison notamment que vous avez évoqué
celle de d'une société plus jeune et qui
n'a peut-être pas encore l'expérience
des autres bien que
quatre mano 5 ans d'expérience ça
commence à être à être important et vous
avez
ce rapport que vous avez présenté à la
presse était assez critique c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire surtout de la
part d'un organisme qui est tenu à une
certaine comment dire un certain
vocabulaire un certain façon de parler
un peu comme nous c'est des mots qui
sont quand même assez forts vous avez
utilisé le statu quo n'est pas possible
pour Tik Tok vous l'avez appelé un
rattra accéléré pour faire face à ces
obligations actuelles et futures
entre autres entre autres critiques
alors je voulais vous vous posez la
première question par rapport à ce
rapport qui est date de novembre donc il
a dit à quelques mois 5 mois maintenant
presque 5 mois est-ce qu'il y a du
nouveau où en est-on par rapport aux
demandes que vous aviez formulées dans
ce rapport est-ce que Tik Tok est revenu
vers vous je sais qu'il est revenu vers
vous puisque le 13 mars c'est-à-dire il
y a très très peu de temps cette semaine
le
représentant institutionnel je me
rappelle plus le conseiller général a
été reçu par rock Olivier Mestre est-ce
que cet entretien a amené des choses
nouvelles et notamment une réponse aux
questions que vous aviez posé dans ce
rapport ou en tout cas une réponse
partielle ou
l'expression de difficulté à
suivre vos recommandations c'est ma
première question la deuxième question
vous aviez
vient d'une de la deuxième chose que
vous avez exprimée tout à l'heure en ce
qui concernait les personnes morales
contrôlées par un état et vous avez pris
l'exemple de cctn le problème se pose
c'est presque évident pour ces CTN en
revanche il se pose sur TikTok et je
voudrais vous poser la question à ce
sujet la maison mère de Tik Tok Bayonne
c'est donc comme toutes les sociétés
chinoises tenues un certain nombre de
choses la première la loi chinoise qui
oblige toutes les sociétés et à
fortiorer les plateformes à déférer à
toutes les demandes et à coopérer c'est
le terme de la loi avec les services de
renseignement chinois deuxièmement dans
la direction du Tik Tok il y a une
cellule du Parti communiste chinois et
de baid dance pardon il y a une cellule
de Parti communiste chinois il me semble
que ça suffit ou en tout cas que c'est
des éléments pour caractériser le
contrôle par un état d'une société
est-ce que l'art comme fait la même
interprétation et c'est à dire que Biden
d'une manière ou d'une autre est une
personne morale contrôlée au sens de
l'article 233 du Code de commerce c'est
ma deuxième question
la troisième je l'ai déjà posé en partie
est-ce que vous pourriez mais au-delà de
de ce que je possède dans ma première
question est-ce que lors de la réunion
du lundi 13 mars entre monsieur Andersen
et Monsieur recolivier Mestre il y a eu
d'autres sujets
éventuellement vous avez le droit
d'évoquer mais d'autres sujets qui ont
été évoqués qui pourraient être
intéressant pour notre commission
le quatrième question c'est est-ce que
la recommande sera le 18 service
escortateur pour la France du DSA parce
que vous savez que le DSA met en place
des digital sur coordinateur pour chaque
pays européen est-ce que c'est déjà
décidé et est-ce que l'art comme sera le
digital service coordinateur pour la
France ou est-ce que ce n'est pas encore
décidé
cinquième question est-ce que l'arcom
est satisfaite des mesures mises en
oeuvre par le réseau Tic-Toc pour
vérifier l'âge de ses utilisateurs ce
que c'est un sujet qui intéresse
particulièrement je l'ai vu lors des
auditions précédentes particulièrement
certains de nos sénateurs et sénatrices
les étudiateurs doivent être
âgées d'au moins 13 ans il semble bien
que
beaucoup beaucoup d'utilisateurs sont
des enfants et aménage bien inférieur
celui de 13 ans est-ce que il y a un
moyen de de vérifier la politique du Tik
Tok et est-ce que elle vous paraît
suffisante en la matière
sinon quelle recommandation est-ce que
vous leur avez faite
de la même façon à ce que l'arcom est
satisfaite des mesures prises par le
réseau TikTok pour limiter le temps
d'utilisation alors commencez le temps
d'utilisation est limité de façon
drastique en Chine puisque au bout de 40
minutes on est déconnecté
ceux qui montrent d'ailleurs que Tik Tok
lui-même se méfie sans doute des
retentissements en matière d'addiction
et d'autres pour ces utilisateurs ils
ont annoncé qu'ils allaient appuyer
cette politique en Europe et notamment
en France mais d'une part d'une façon
beaucoup plus modérée c'est à dire non
pas en déconnectant mais en prévenant
qu'on est au bout d'une heure donc ce
qui laisse l'utilisateur pouvoir
continuer de le faire est-ce que à votre
connaissance ce système a été mis en
place ou est-ce que comme c'est souvent
le cas de la part des plateformes c'est
une annonce et puis on l'a satisfera le
jour où on voudra
je voulais vous demander enfin que
pensez-vous des interdictions c'était le
sujet important parce qu'il est
d'actualité et qu'il ouvre une boîte de
Pandore évidemment la Commission
européenne le Parlement européen
viennent d'interdire comme beaucoup de
gouvernements de plus en plus
le gouvernement américain notamment
canadien et plusieurs gouvernements
européens à leur fonctionnaires
d'utiliser l'application TikTok sur leur
téléphone professionnel et de
déconseiller fortement d'utiliser sur
leur téléphone personnel quelques
pensez-vous de ces interdictions
évidemment
si c'est le cas de la Commission
européenne et s'il y a est-ce que vous
avez des
puisqu'ils n'ont pas donné la raison
exacte ils ont vaguement par les
transferts de données j'imagine qu'il
n'avaient pas envie d'un enseignant
diplomatique avec certains gouvernements
extra-européen d'ailleurs
est-ce que
quel est votre réflexion à ce sujet
puisque ça veut dire que si la
Commission européenne
[Musique]
pour se poser problème de transfert de
données
ça concerne tous les européens et
notamment le gouvernement français
notamment l'état français bien entendu
donc
quelle conclusion en direz-vous de ce
point de vue là
que pensez-vous du projet Clover
représente un ancien récemment par
l'aéroport anticock en Europe qui
consiste à
localiser les centres de données sur le
sol de l'Union européenne parce que je
rappelle qu'actuellement si je ne me
trompe pas ça ne l'est pas c'est à
Singapour et aux États-Unis est-ce que
ça vous paraît suffisant pour
assurer la sécurité Dieudonné est-ce que
vous pensez que ce qui
est allégé par pas mal de chercheurs en
informatique les bacs d'or sont toujours
enfin les portes dérobées sont toujours
possibles et que c'est une c'est une
assurance qui paraît bien faible et puis
je voudrais vous poser une dernière
question qui date de cette nuit dans la
saga de
[Musique]
US coverman versus Tik Tok si on peut
dire et qui dure depuis déjà un certain
temps
cette nuit nous avons appris la décision
du gouvernement américain après beaucoup
de de discussions et de préparation de
projet de loi voire de menaces
interdiction qui vient de demander à
Biden devant Tik Tok un petit peu de la
même façon que le gouvernement américain
avait demandé à queinder avait forcé la
vente de grinder étant donné évidemment
les les menaces de chantage évidentes
qui pouvaient exister par rapport aux
utilisateurs de la part d'un
gouvernement non démocratique donc
voilà si vous avez vous avez peut-être
pas eu le temps de vous pencher sur ce
sujet mais si par hasard vous avez une
première impression
j'aimerais bien que vous nous disiez ce
que vous en pensez
merci monsieur le rapporteur pour ces
questions j'aime permettre d'évacuer une
partie des questions toutes celles qui
ont très à la protection de la vie
privée à la protection des données
l'arcom n'a aucune compétence sur le
sujet nous n'avons pas ce mandat nous
n'avons pas développé cette compétence
et nous suivrons les consignes
gouvernementales comme toutes les
services de l'État si consignes
gouvernementales il y a sur le sujet
si je reprends vos questions je crois
que dans l'ordre alors
Tik Tok a effectivement quatre ou cinq
ans d'expérience on les a épinglé
et derrière alors on se bat avec toutes
les plateformes et avec Tik Tok la
première pour l'ordi ne venez pas
répondre à nos questions vous répondez
publiquement à nos questions nous ne
voulons pas nous être rassurés nous
voulons que tout le monde soit convaincu
de la réalité de ce que vous faites et
c'est intéressant parce que initialement
on demandait aux plateformes
en appliquant la loi de 2018 sera lutte
contre un my PC formation donc faites un
rapport à l'arcom l'art comme fait un
rapport de synthèse pour la première
fois l'année dernière on a dit non vous
vous faites un rapport aux Français on
ces rapports ont été rendus publics dès
qu'on les a reçus et ils ont été
critiqués dans les médias Facebook avait
été un peu accroché par un média
audiovisuel c'est tes revenus vers nous
on leur dit ben oui c'est le but
c'est collectivement qu'on va juger de
la réalité de ce que vous faites et pas
uniquement le régulateur parce que même
si on a quelques moyens nos moyens sont
dérisoirs par rapport à puissance de ces
plateformes et par rapport à la
multiplicité des sujets qu'il faut
apprécier et de savoir que la pertinence
de leur réponse et donc là
dans cette réunion effectivement lundi
soir où était présent le
directeur juridiquement de Tik Tok rock
Olivier Mestre et moi-même et un son
d'autres présentes Tik Tok quelque part
ils m'ont dit oui on a entendu votre
message on travaille à la résolution on
peut vous expliquer et on répond tout de
suite non
vous rendez publique vous devez et donc
on veille mais soigneusement à ce que on
ne s'enferme pas dans un dialogue porte
fermé avec ses plateformes ce qui enjeu
c'est un sujet vraiment de
à la fois d'obtenir qu'elle durcisse
leur plateforme qu'elle soit plus
rigoureuses dans la manière dont elle
légère et à la fois de préserver la
confiance dans nos espaces
informationnels ce sont des plateformes
d'information et donc c'est
collectivement qu'on doit réussir à se
convaincre qu'elles sont plus
responsables et donc de ce point de vue
là je vous décevrez toujours parce que
encore une fois nous repoussons en
permanence leur tentative de dire on est
prêt à vous en dire plus on dit non nous
ne voulons pas en savoir plus nous
voulons que collectivement nous
insachions plus pour que collectivement
nous puissions critiquer au sens positif
du terme évaluer ce que vous faites et
pour que on puisse obtenir derrière une
réaction et un réajustement quand ça
n'est pas satisfaisant ces sujets sont
trop importants parce que simplement
pour pas vous faire revenir là-dessus
après est-ce qu'on peut faire un
parallèle avec les recommandations que
font certains certains grands d'une part
et puis des services plus étatique
d'autre part sur les questions de
cybersécurité consistant à dire il faut
partager l'information quand on l'a subi
une attaque il ça sert à rien de le
garder pour soi d'essayer de faire en
sorte que ça ne se voit pas au contraire
il faut entre nous dans l'écosystème
partager l'information dire ce qui s'est
passé pour que collectivement on résove
le problème et de ne pas être selon
l'expression consacrée en silo est-ce
que sur la question du contrôle de la
qualité de l'information c'est la même
logique que vous proposez là de
d'adopter de développer elle est poussée
encore beaucoup plus loin beaucoup plus
loin parce que
[Musique]
il y a une vérité scientifique de la
sécurité
alors que là on parle d'information
et sur l'information il n'y a pas de
ministère de la Vérité et donc il s'agit
vraiment de créer la confiance de tout
le monde et de surtout veiller à ce que
tout le monde puisse se forger son
opinion puisse apprécier puisse
critiquer et pour que on rassemble les
gens dans cette démarche collective on
décentralise la régulation c'est aussi
une condition là où on rejoint par
rapport à ces persécurité de
mobilisation collective de dire
effectivement ne nous en formons pas
individuellement chacun face à nos
difficultés c'est collectivement c'est
une question qui taraude tout le monde
depuis maintenant un salon d’années au
niveau français qu'au niveau européen
qu'au niveau américain comment répondre
à la puissance de la globalité des
plateformes et la réponse c'est avec la
puissance de la démocratie en mobilisant
une démarche totalement horizontale et
en permettant à tout le monde de
participer à cet exercice
et la première audition auquel vous avez
procédé avec Marc Fadoul était
extrêmement importante pour nous c'est
l'enjeu de mobiliser la le monde
académique quand vous y réfléchissez
comment est-ce qu'on comment est-ce
qu'on régule
la presse
la loi d'ici en 80
interventions du juge derrière et
pourtant en fait 680 c'est avant tout
une obligation transparence
exil liberté de la presse mais exigence
de faire un dépôt légal de dire tout le
monde peut voir la presse
oui
mais quand vous prenez certains mais
quand vous prenez certains médias
complotistes ça les arrête pas quand
vous regardez comment Monsieur prigori
ne construit des fausses informations il
crée un site web avec la responsabilité
du Directeur de la publication et ça
suffit pas à l'arrêter donc il faut pas
les réel mais elle n'est pas mis en
oeuvre si souvent et en fait il y a une
autre régulation qui se fait qui fonder
sur la transparence ou tous les médias
se critiquent et se surveillent entre
eux toutes les universités de français
de Navarre ont un département Sciences
de l'Information sciences politiques
sciences sociales qui analysent comment
fonctionne l'écosystème médiatique et
qui crée des cordes de rappel
on le voit et c'est ça qu'il faut
recréer aujourd'hui on a une asymétrie
d'information beaucoup trop forte entre
ces plateformes la réalité de ce
qu'elles font et cette transparence qui
est facile à exiger sur des médias
éditorialisés et très dur à construire
sur des médias algorithmiques parce
qu'ils traite l'information à l'échelle
et en individualisant le contenu vous
observez votre TikTok j'observe mon
compte Facebook mais ça ne me dit pas ce
qu'il y a sur le vote parce que ce que
je vois c'est le résultat de toute une
série de traitements algorithmiques qui
sont individualisés avec les
informations qui détiennent sur moi et
donc si on veut comprendre ce qu'ils
font il faut comprendre comment ils
fonctionnent à l'échelle comment est-ce
que leurs algorithmes sculpte
l'information version très optimiste qui
peuvent en traitant l'information mettre
en avant les contenus qui renforcent la
prise de conscience du besoin de gérer
la transition écologique
personne négative veut pas faire le
contraire et donc il faut arriver à
détruire cette asymétrie d'information
et ça passe par le fait que grâce aux
règlements sur le service numérique
européen on va pouvoir exiger une
transparence
sortante où ils vont révéler une
information qu'ils ont quelle est
l'intention qu'ils ont mis dans leurs
algorithmes mais on va pouvoir exiger
une transparence entrante ou de
l'extérieur on va pouvoir révéler des
informations qu'ils n'ont pas qui sont
éventuellement est-ce que leurs
algorithmes ont des effets non
intentionnels ou révéler des choses qui
essaient de nous cacher
et donc vous avez eu un exemple
formidable avec les travaux de Marc
Fadoul qui ont été présentés lundi ou
sans qu'il ait besoin de la coopération
de la plateforme il a développé des
travaux d'observation où il peut révéler
des comportements de la plateforme on
peut révéler des effets des bielles
algorithmiques révélés qu’éventuellement
un algorithme a pour effet de pousser
trop le contenu qui vont augmenter les
problèmes d'obésité d'obésité en France
et ça ça fait partie du modèle de
régulation et c'est ça qu'il faut
arriver à passer à l'échelle aussi et
donc à l'échelle ça veut dire à ce que
dans toutes nos universités les
départements de sciences politiques de
sciences sociales de sciences de
l'information dans des travaux
interdisciplinaires arrivent à se saisir
de ces sujets pour révéler la où sont
les difficultés où sont les risques et
pour évaluer collectivement la
pertinence des réponses de ces
plateformes
et donc ça c'est vraiment le l'enjeu le
plus fort et donc on martèle ça à Tik
Tok Tik Tok et une loi commence à nous
dire j'ai commencé à mettre en place un
programme d'accès des chercheurs aux
données voilà
ou sont les où est l'information
est-elle publique qu'ils sont les
laboratoires qui peuvent s'en saisir
vont-ils être en mesure de faire des
recherches de manière indépendante c'est
des sujets tellement importants que on
s'en est déjà saisi avant même
l'adoption du règlement sur les services
numériques l'arcom a lancé une
consultation publique sur l'accès des
chercheurs aux données des grandes
plateformes
[Musique]
à l'été dernier en juillet dernier le
règlement était pas encore adopté mais
on savait l'accord politique est
dépassée donc on savait que c'était
l'élément était déjà présent dans le
règlement parce qu'il y a tout un
travail de mobilisation et on est en
train d'armer une mécanique extrêmement
puissante parce qu'elle est
décentralisée dans nos démocraties alors
vous me demandez est-ce que est-ce que
c'est une personne morale contrôlée au
sens de l'article du commerce on n'a pas
répondu à la question en tant que tel
parce que d'abord elle a pas de
conséquences juridique pour nous dans le
cadre juridique actuel mais au-delà
j'aurais tendance à dire
que ce contrôle soit réel ou fantasmé ça
a quasiment le même effet
ça au sens où ça va ça exigera de Tik
Tok un effort supplémentaire par rapport
à d'autres plateformes pour recréer la
confiance légitime et on a essayé de
leur faire toucher ça du doigt en disant
mais c'est un état de fait et donc
compte tenu d'une part que vous n'avez
pas construit il y a un vrai décalage
effectivement vous avez cité les propos
qu'on a eu dans la conférence de presse
en disant le statu quo est pas possible
et
je souhaite insister sur ce point-là
parce que vous avez ce retard de
jeunesse vous avez un retard que
l'entreprise elle-même l'expliquait
lundi soir qualifie un peu de culturel
en disant mais nous ne sommes pas encore
une entreprise côté donc nous ne sommes
pas habitués à ces obligations de
transparence qui viennent de la
réglementation des marchés financiers
mais au-delà on sent que effectivement
cette entreprise n'a pas eu la même
naissance que les grandes plateformes
américaines qui sont nées avec une
pression de la société civile américaine
beaucoup plus forte et le règlement
c'est le service numérique toute la
démarche européenne a été construite en
disant
on ne peut pas se satisfaire de la
démarche américaine qui repose avec un
socle très léger juridique cette section
230 qui était l'équivalent de la
directive e-commerce en Europe et d'une
autorégulation
[Musique]
sous pression de la société civile qui à
la fois est bonne il y a on a pu le voir
il y a un acquis énorme et on a réalisé
cet acquis en typiquement en comparant
avec TiK ToK on n'avait pas cette acquis
et à la fois déjà pour les Américains on
n'est pas suffisant on n'en veut plus en
Europe et donc c'est pour ça que
l'Europe avec la présidente française et
allemande a construit tout ce régime
mais on voit qu'il est encore plus
nécessaire pour Tik Tok parce que il y a
tous ces décalages à rattraper décalages
de jeunesse décalage culturel et en plus
cette suspicion réelle ou non on n'a pas
besoin de la bien mais qui crée qui qui
peut éroder la confiance et qui justifie
que la plateforme en fasse plus et c'est
le type de discussion qu'on a la
discussion qu'on a eu avec eux et c'est
de leur dire mais vous allez devoir en
faire plus si vous voulez ne serait-ce
qu'arriver au niveau de vos collègues
des plateformes Facebook Twitter ou
Instagram
je poursuis dans la réponse à vos
questions
je vous remercie de la question piège
allons-nous être le DSC le choix du DSC
c'est le choix du ça se formalisera par
une loi et en France et le Parlement qui
vote les lois sur proposition du
gouvernement donc
mais ce que je veux dire nous nous y
préparons nous sommes candidats
toutes les lois votées par le Parlement
français depuis 5 ans nous demande de
nous y préparer nous avons été
extrêmement engagés dans le le débat
dans la construction la France du DSA et
l'arcom se prépare donc je vous le dis
c'est cet exemple vous avez cet article
40 dans le Règlement sur les services
numériques qui donnent ce droit d'accès
à des chercheurs qualifiés aux données
des plateformes qui est une mécanique
extrêmement puissante mais qui va être
compliqué à mettre en oeuvre parce qu'il
va falloir l'articuler avec le droit à
la protection privée et donc avec le
règlement général de la protection des
données et donc depuis déjà un an nous
travaillons pieds à pied avec l'acnil à
nos côtés pour commencer à mobiliser les
équipes de recherche et avec l'espoir
que la France sera à l'avant-garde de la
mise en œuvre du DSA parce que le
règlement sur le service numérique à la
fois crée une dynamique européenne qui
va donner une puissance bien plus forte
et à la fois laisse l'espace à ce que
chaque pays s'engage lui-même pour
revenir je pense que c'est un point
important de à comprendre on prend on va
avoir toute une série d'inquiétudes
légitimes sur les plateformes qui vont
se construire sur les travaux des
enquêtes journalistes des travaux de
recherche médicaux des travaux de
recherche d'un département de sociologie
sur un manipulation d'information
et ça en fait c'est dans la construction
du règlement européen c'est ce qu'on
appelle un risque systémique de dire ben
voilà les très grandes plateformes sont
soumets une obligation de dire par leur
existence elle provoque des risques
systémiques dans nos sociétés le
règlement pré-identifier le risque
systémique manipulation de la formation
et le règlement exige pour être très
grande plateforme comme TikTok de dire
dès lors que vous êtes désigné très
grande plateforme vous devez
identifier vos systémique et les rendre
public
prendre des plans de réduction du risque
et les rendre publics les soumettre à
des audits pour vérifier que ce que vous
annoncez vous le mettez effectivement en
œuvre et en plus par le biais de l'accès
des chercheurs aux données vous
soumettre à des évaluations
indépendantes et le système est itératif
et donc la dynamique du règlement
européen c'est ça aussi qu'on a retenu
des expériences des lois françaises et
allemandes il faut construire dans le
règlement une capacité d'adaptation au
problème du futur pour ne pas courir
toujours après les problèmes et avoir
bien des lois qui sont adaptatives c'est
aussi pour ça qu'on a introduit à
résoudre régulateur dedans on est un
ingrédient qui n'était pas présent dans
la directive e-commerce pour utiliser et
activer cette boîte à outils et donc on
va avoir un exercice itératif les
premiers les premiers exercices vont
être décevants ils vont revenir en
disant avec un schéma en disant tout va
bien j'ai identifié mes risques et la
dynamique va se lancer les régulateurs
vont s'engager on va mobiliser et donc
vous voyez c'est régulateur ou les
mentionné la question qui va être le le
coordinateur pour les services
numériques le CSN en français le DSC en
anglais pour le il y a ce mot
coordinateur qui est mis pour dire à
quel point le régulateur n'est pas un
régulateur qui va tout ramener à lui
mais que au contraire va veiller à ce
que tout le monde puisse participer à
cet exercice pour critiquer ses efforts
et donc et on voit que ça fonctionne y
compris donc avec des approches qu'on
n'a pas on peut éviter d'aller mettre
des sanctions parce que le but est pas
de mettre des sanctions le but est
d'arriver à obtenir quelques
comportements se modifient et donc
effectivement on voit que la plateforme
est déjà en train d'entendre le souffle
du boulet européen et dit ah oui bon je
vais peut-être mettre en place des
outils de réduction du temps du temps
d'écran on a le même question que vous
en disant vous avez fait une annonce les
annonces ça ne vaut rien où sont les
éléments est-ce que c'est tangible ou
pas et on commence à avoir ces
dynamiques positives c'est ça qui est en
train de se préparer assez à ça qu'on se
prépare à la com
sur le
je ne sais pas si on peut comparer la
situation américaine et la situation
européenne parce que
jusqu'à il y a peu les deux situations
étaient comparables au sens où
l'Union européenne et les États-Unis
avaient mis en place un régime juridique
qui était propice au développement des
plateformes c'est la directive irremerce
avec son régime de responsabilité
limitée à raison des contenus quelles
sont l'équivalent américain qui a la
section 230
là où les deux continents divergent
c'est que la dynamique poétique aux
États-Unis est bloquée
et il y a non interroge tous les acteurs
tous qu'on rencontre qui vient des
États-Unis et on dit mais est-ce qu'il y
a une perspective qu'il y a des grandes
lois qui soient votées aux États-Unis et
la réponse on dit non et donc les
Américains sont bloqués avec la section
230 et rien d'autre là où l'Europe a
voté ce règlement sur les services
numériques et qui est donc ça ça peut
changer la situation parce que c'est
effectivement une capacité et c'est
intéressant parce qu'on voit
énormément d'engagement qui vient
d'Amérique du Nord vers l'Europe pour
nous aider à réussir le démarrage de ce
règlement parce que ils sont en train
d'en voir le potentiel
et une question si je peux me permettre
que qui a pas été posée à Marc Fadoul
lundi c'est de savoir comment est-ce
qu'il finance ses travaux
et en partie la réponse est par des
financements qui viennent de fondation
américaine
et là il y a un enjeu énorme
c'est-à-dire que comment est-ce qu'on va
plus loin pour mettre en œuvre et
réussir la mettre en œuvre la mise en
œuvre du Règlement sur les services
numériques il faut d'abord une loi qui
va faire la partie institutionnelle en
France mais il y a un enjeu de savoir
comment on lance des programmes de
financement de la recherche publique
parce qu'en France on sera plus dans des
et en Europe en général plus dans des
logiques de financement public que de
financement par des fondations privées
pour relancer des programmes
multidisciplinaires dans toutes les
université de France et de Navarre pour
que on se saisisse de ces sujets on
analyse où sont les dynamiques sur ces
nouvelles plateformes ou certes une
partie viennent il y a des bas de guys
il y a des méchants mais il y a aussi
beaucoup de sujets qui sont simplement
qui viennent de nos comportements de nos
usages du numérique et qui vaut mieux
comprendre pour pouvoir mieux pour
pouvoir y répondre pour pouvoir
mobiliser et créer un nouveau sentiment
de citoyenneté numérique du côté des
usagers et pour pouvoir faire des
nouvelles demandes en disant on découvre
qu'il y a un nouveau risque systémique
qui découle qui n'est certes ça n'était
pas votre intention mais qui est très
réel et sur lequel on vous demande de
vous mobiliser et aujourd'hui la
question qu'on a c'est comment on peut
espérer multiplier les travaux comme
ceux qui sont mis en oeuvre par Marc
Fadoul par le laboratoire de recherche
de Sciences Po le média là bas à Paris
par les équipes qui sont à Lille qu'on
que je vais aller rencontrer dans une
semaine par des équipes qui sont aussi à
l'université d'Aix-Marseille c'est un
travail collectif
et il faudra un financement pour ces
travaux et qui sont interdisciplinaires
parce qu'à chaque fois il faut croiser
des recherches en santé publique et en
sciences d'information des recherches en
sociologie en sens d'information et
stimuler et utiliser le potentiel de de
nos université qui est l'endroit aussi
accent où vous avez
des jeunes et des cerveaux qui sont
capables de s'approprier ces
technologies numériques ces technologies
d'intelligence artificielle qui est
aussi un autre défi de savoir comment on
crée ses capacités institutionnelles
aujourd'hui on a des lots la loi
européenne qui vient d'être votée est
très puissante et maintenant la question
c'est à quelle vitesse on construit les
institutions et les hommes et les femmes
pour les mettre en oeuvre donc l'enjeu
aussi d'aller chercher les chercheurs
c'est très opportuniste c'est aussi
l'enjeu d'aller chercher les enseignants
et leurs étudiants qui sont à côté d'eux
pour les amener à s'engager dans la mise
en œuvre de ce règlement
ce que vous aviez épuisé les questions
de monsieur le rapporteur ou pas non
[Musique]
vous n'avez posé la question sur
votre opinion sur les interdictions
Commission européenne Parlement européen
des utilisations de l'application par
les fonctionnaires des téléphones etc
c'est un problème de sécurité des
données
on n'a pas compétence sur le sujet et
donc on attend s'il y a une décision des
autorités publiques françaises nous la
suivrons comme tous les services de
l'État merci
je vais poser une petite question puis
après je vais passer aux collègues j'en
avais prévu mais votre dernier point que
vous évoquez parce que c'est intéressant
de voir finalement dans les politiques
publiques
on réinvente pas l'eau chaude
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des il y a des
postures et des façons de faire qui
s'agissant du contrôle de gros acteurs
économiques peuvent être un peu les
mêmes vous avez parlé au début de votre
intervention d'une question de
citoyenneté numérique je vois bien que
c'est ça qui irrigue l'ensemble sur la
question du contrôle de la prise de
conscience collective du caractère de
l'impératif démocratique de tout cela
mais de la même façon que d'un point de
vue écologique on a mis en oeuvre puis
développer de secteurs en secteur des
questions par exemple déco participation
quelle les gens sont parfaitement
habitués maintenant quand ils ont un
appareil électroménager ou quelque chose
ils savent qui paye pour un changement
une écho-participation quand on voit les
milliards qui sont investis par les
grandes entreprises de la
du numérique ou certaines plateformes
qui font comment dire l'ensemble de leur
développement d'un point de vue
numérique je pense notamment à Amazon
enfin j'ai plus le chiffre en tête mais
ce sont des ça dépasse la quinzaine de
milliards je crois enfin
d'investissement dans leur recherche et
développement est-ce qu'il y a pas là un
vivier sur lequel on peut aller taper
entre guillemets avec le même état
d'esprit que des questions
d'éco-participation que eux-mêmes
participent au financement de leur
propre contrôle
et est-ce que ça vaut pour tout le monde
tant pour Tik Tok puis j'aurai une autre
petite question après
le Règlement sur les services numériques
prévoit effectivement qui doivent
contribuer au financement de la fonction
de régulation
donc après donc il y a déjà la
Commission européenne c'est lancée et
préfinance son activité mais c'est pour
ça que le premier acte qu'ils font c'est
de désigner les très grandes plateformes
et du coup d'amorcer le mécanisme
financier qui va les amener à contribuer
au financement de leur propre régulation
mais au-delà effectivement nous on se
bat avec eux pour obtenir que qui
s'engage effectivement pour beaucoup il
y a un enjeu économique qui est
phénoménal le
en quoi l'auto-régulation était
insatisfait elle était insatisfaisante
parce qu'on voyait bien que au sein même
de ces entreprises
l'allocation des moyens entre
financier la croissance le développement
et financé la stabilisation la gestion
proactive des effets intentionnels
étaient inadéquate et que les
incitations n'étaient pas les bonnes et
donc effectivement
le règlement vise à les forcer justement
à enlever cette degré de liberté à leur
dire ça n'est plus justement de de la
bonne gestion à votre initiative c'est
une obligation légale et le régime de
sanctions est très sévère qui peut être
activé si il y avait défaut de moyens et
donc on va les forcer à investir et à
déplacer les curseurs et notamment il y
a une lutte de savoir où vont les
ingénieurs dans ces dans ces maisons à
savoir à développer le dernier produit
ou à mettre à niveau tout l'exercice de
reporting de mesure des effets pervers
et typiquement c'est le c'est le
reproche qu'on fait à Tik Tok quand on
dit que le statut quo n'est pas possible
c'est que c'est bien que les moyens qui
ont été mis à assurer la croissance de
son activité l'ont été au détriment de
la croissance au même moment de tous les
mécanismes de stabilisation et c'est en
ça qu'on a dénoncé que le statu quo
n'était pas possible et sans ça qu'on a
dit mais les lois français ne suivent
pas il faut basculer sur la loi
européenne c'est la première urgence
maintenant avant de passer la parole je
pense que ça s'appelle juste un oui ou
un nom vous avez dit que vous n'aviez
pas constaté dans le cadre de l'élection
du Président de la République de de
d'éléments il y a eu entre guillemets
parce que vous avez appelé la diversion
des événements en Ukraine qui ont fait
que vous n'avez pas eu à traiter ce
problème là il nous avons connu un
scrutin sur lequel il y avait des
craintes exprimées publiquement
d'ingérence et non des moindres qui est
un peu liés à Tik Tok sur la
Nouvelle-Calédonie au monde du
référendum tout pareil vous n'avez pas
eu à relever de l'incident particulier
c'est intéressant ou de mentionner parce
qu'effectivement quand en 2021
on a commencé à se préparer à l'élection
présidentielle
on essaye avec toutes ces grandes
plateformes de nouer une relation avec
de confiance et notamment avec les gens
qui sont amenés à prendre les décisions
le cas d'échée en période de crise pour
être sûr que si c'est le cas on puisse
établir tout de suite une relation avec
eux avec la commission électorale avec
le Conseil nécessaire et on était dans
une telle discussion avec Google et
avant qu'on ait posé la question on a
bien compris vous avez l'élection
présidentielle on sera mobilisé et on
leur a répondu oui mais avant on a une
élection qui a lieu en
Nouvelle-Calédonie donc là on a vu les
yeux et on dit l'Indopacifique
l'actualité a fait que brutalement ils
ont situé et effectivement et c'est
intéressant parce que on voit que c'est
le sur le coup ils nous ont regardé mais
il y a 200 000 habitants
c'était tout petit alors échelle et en
fait la réponse a été tout de suite de
dire mais
maintenant que vous nous le dites oui on
sait mettre le focus pour surveiller
cette zone dans la période où c'est
important pour vous et donc on voit que
c'est ce type de relation intéressantes
qu'on peut construire et on retrouve ça
dans le cadre européen aussi où il y a
un rôle une coopération intelligente à
faire entre les pays sur lesquels
ces plateformes opère les sociétés
civiles les autorités publiques et les
plateformes pour obtenir leur
mobilisation là où c'est important au
bon moment et effectivement à l'époque
on avait envoyé les demandes à Facebook
à Google
à l'époque Tik Tok était la loi ne s'est
appliquée pas mais on avait mobilisé
tout le monde pour dire suivons cette
élection parce que à cette échelle il y
a le risque est là à ma connaissance là
aussi rien n'a été constaté
c'était ça la question et est-ce que
vous diriez comme l'a évoqué monsieur
Fadoul l'autre jour mais vous l'a dit
plus qu'en filigrane mais ce qu'on peut
dire de manière un peu
un peu sèchement que cette entreprise
est dit non c'est pas oui est-ce que les
ingénieurs les moyens sont mis sur là où
ça doit être mis ou sur le développement
du dernier produit pour faire de
l'argent est-ce qu'il est-ce qu'ils sont
débordés par leur propre développement
ou le
constaté ce décalage nous avons fait ce
constat nous avons constaté le décalage
entre le succès commercial fulgurant et
le fait que le cet engagement et cette
prise de conscience de leur
responsabilité au moment même où le les
lois françaises étaient connus
elle n'aurait pas immédiatement
applicable parce qu'il n'est pas la
taille mais il voyait comment les
appliquer avec leurs concurrents ils
s'observent les uns les autres et on
voit l'enjeu particulier
d'y faire face parce que vous voyez
aussi à quel point le succès fulgurant
de Tik Tok a des conséquences
concurrentielles Facebook a modifié méta
à modifier
le fonctionnement d'Instagram pour
essayer de suivre Tik Tok et c'est la
pression de ces usagers qui l'a arrêté
regardez sur Youtube vous voyez qu'il y
a un nouveau format qui est apparu de
vidéo très courte
sur le même modèle que Tik Tok donc on
voit à quel point effectivement leur
succès a des conséquences sur les autres
et à quel point il est nécessaire
d'avoir un cadre européen qui n'est pas
relève pas de la bonne volonté des
acteurs mais qui est exigé pour empêcher
justement ces décalages entre la
concurrence commerciale et qui se fasse
au prix d'une des responsabilisation des
acteurs
alors André gatolin est-ce que d'autres
collègues souhaitent poser une question
à ce stade et après monsieur dessus très
bien
oui merci monsieur le Président oui
monsieur une première remarque je suis
resté un peu sur ma faim quand on vous a
posé la question de la spécificité de la
spécificité de Tik Tok vous avez dit
c'est un média jeune bon d'accord la
jeunesse peut expliquer la croissance
j'aurais aimé peut-être plus de
caractérisation contenu des compétences
de l'arcome y compris en termes de
nature de contenu ça c'est la première
chose je pense que c'est pas le seul
qualificatif qu'on pourrait avoir
notamment il y en ayant en particulier
alors on parle des conséquences
l'addiction il y a l'usage systématique
au-delà des vidéos courtes des systèmes
de défi de challenge qui incite des
groupes de jeunes à la transgression et
la sur transgression c'est un phénomène
qu'on a très peu aux pratiquesment pas
sur les autres réseaux sociaux après je
sais pas si vous avez des services qui
suivent un petit peu ou qui est en
dessous les contenus de Tik Tok mais
c'est quand même
intéressant l'autre aspect qui se pose
c'est celui de la censure il se trouve
que je travaille depuis quelques années
sur la question des ingérences
étrangères le nombre de personnes qui
m'ont contacté
à ce propos notamment de chercheurs qui
ont eu le malheur de passer un court
message soutenant les 8 gourds ont vu
non seulement leur message supprimé puis
leur compte fermer donc je pense que on
a un vrai problème en France on a une
plateforme sur un certain nombre de
délits qui s'appelle farros qui
fonctionne bien on n'a pas de plateforme
un peu neutre et ouverte de
fonctionnement d'ailleurs je vous
conseille de prendre langue avec la
division strat 2 du service d'action
extérieur de l'Union européenne qui est
une ras rapides qui s'intéresse à la
désinformation moi j'ai beaucoup échangé
avec eux malheureusement je vais pêcher
des signalements concernant la France
sur leur plateforme ce qui est quand
même un tout petit peu paradoxal il faut
connaître son existence et sans ce
retour par exemple des logiques
éditoriales qui sont pas simplement des
volontés logiques d'influence mais des
censures qui sont fait explicitement
comme celles que je rappelais ne seront
jamais dans les cas donc la question ne
serait jamais posée enfin je voulais
vous demander quel type de collaboration
coopération sur le cas de Tik Tok
puisque c'est un cas comme assez
particulier et international vous avez
avec les autres régulateurs membres de
l'ergat est-ce que à ma connaissance il
y a eu des sollicitations qui ont été
faites auprès des autorités de
régulation néerlandaises sur TikTok il y
a un dossier on parle beaucoup du
Danemark ou d'autres du Canada mais il y
a un certain nombre de questions qui se
posent au Pays-Bas moi je change
beaucoup avec mes collègues
parlementaires des différents pays je me
dis on a un problème quand même un peu
en France de parents gonnage et sur un
sujet comme ça il est intéressant que
vous homologues même si des fois les
périmètres sont pas tout à fait les
mêmes
soit suivi voilà
j'insistais sur cette sur ces questions
là parce que je crois notamment que le
problème que je posais c'est à dire
l'incitation sur un public dans ces
naturellement un petit peu la tendance
qu'on tenait de l'âge à la transgression
est extrêmement gênante parce que la
conservation des données leur traitement
peut amener à des formes il y a plus de
deux il y a pas de droit à l'oubli si on
a un opérateur extérieur et évidemment
dans ces statuts et d'endroits
international
Tik Tok a le droit de transférer à sa
maison mère les données après c'est
l'usage qui est en effet et le fait
qu'il n'y ait pas de régulation type
rgpd qui s'applique au pays qui qui
demande en l'occurrence lâcher donc tous
ces aspects-là on aimerait les voir en
lumière on parlait de silos on aimerait
approcher quand même Tik Tok alors j'ai
bien compris qu'il y a des choses qui
sont pas de votre sœur mais de manière
systémique puisque la plateforme a un
fonctionnement systémique comme beaucoup
d'ailleurs de ces grandes plateformes
mais en particulier de toutes les
stratégies d'influence qui émanent de la
République populaire de Chine voilà donc
système d'alerte est-ce que le CSA ou à
l'instar de farose ça pourrait exister
parce que ça rend un sens sachant que
vous pouvez pas aller voir les contenus
de chaque personne et les chercheurs ont
de grandes qualités je suis d'obtention
de la formation et communication et
enseignants on a beaucoup de mal y
compris quand on demande des recherches
sur le sujet d'arriver à construire qui
est une des choses qui ne validité en
termes d'observation des contenus qui
est de validité scientifique qui soit
pas du pure aléatoire ou de constat
personnel ou d'un échantillon non
représentatif de personnes
en fait vous noterez qu'il y a un
décalage
on est intarissable à documenter les
défauts de Twitter puisqu'on réels et on
ne sait très peu de choses sur Tik Tok
et la différence et que Twitter qui a
beaucoup de défauts mais le twitter
alors peut-être d'avoir Elon Musk a
toujours de très très tôt mis en place à
un accès massif assédé pour les
chercheurs et pour les médias via une
interface de programmation une API l'API
Twitter et c'est parce qu'ils ont fait
ça que on est un tarissable à dénoncé et
défauts de Twitter et c'est pour ça que
j'insiste sur ce point parce que nous
souhaitons via le cadre européen mettre
en place l'API de Tik Tok pour que
arrêter parce que nous ne vont pas
minimiser les défauts Twitter qui sont
réels mais nous vont juste que les gens
prennent conscience que si on est aussi
compétent c'est parce qu'ils permettent
cette transparence si on connaît
beaucoup de défauts de Facebook c'est
aussi parce que Facebook avait créé un
outil qui s'appelle crowd Tangle qui
permet beaucoup d'observations et qui a
été axé qui était accessible par les
médias américains beaucoup de des
reportages qui ont été faits par les
médias américains qui caractérisent les
défauts de facebook venaient de
l'exploitation de ces données
aujourd'hui crowdanger et la pays de
Twitter c'était deux exemples sur lequel
qui relevait de l'initiative de ces deux
entreprises à tout moment elles peuvent
disparaître
et c'est pour ça que il y a eu une
bataille très forte pour loger dans le
Règlement sur les services numériques
européens le RSN cet article 40 qui pour
la première fois dit il y a un droit des
chercheurs qualifiés à accéder à ces
données pour participer à la mise en
oeuvre de ce règlement pour répondre
exactement à votre question et on pense
que c'est plus puissant que simplement
dire le régulateur peut
la puissance de ce système en plus on
sait que c'est faisable dans le respect
du règlement général de la protection
des données
on peut totalement ça nous donnera et ça
ne doit pas donner un nouveau Cambridge
Analytica on sait que c'est faisable en
plus parce qu'on le fait en France en
France tous les chercheurs français et
d'ailleurs étrangers peuvent accéder à
toutes les données fiscales des Français
toutes les données sociales des Français
pour dans des buts de recherche dans un
environnement totalement contrôlé ça
s'appelle le Centre d'accès sécurisé des
données c'est un groupement d'intérêts
publics piloté par l'INSEE pour faire
court et dans lequel vous pouvez
demander
en vous faisant agréer en disant voilà
je voudrais faire telle recherche pour
évaluer la pertinence de telles
politiques publiques politiques fiscale
j'ai besoin d'accéder aux données
fiscales pour faire ses recherches les
données vous sont mises à disposition
d'un espace sécurisé tout ce que vous
faites est enregistré pour vérifier
effectivement que vous n'êtes pas en
train d'extraire l'information
personnelle et vous pouvez ressortir les
données
et tout ceci est tamponné et certifié
conforme avec le règlement général de la
protection des données qui s'appliquent
totalement à Tik Tok et donc je veux pas
évacuer la question sur savoir est-ce
que il y a un énorme enjeu de sécurité
de données avec Tik Tok mais c'est
vraiment l'enjeu de faire respecter le
rgpd c'est l'enjeu des CNI européenne
qui s'en sont saisis simplement nous
harcom nous ne sommes pas responsables
et nous n'avons pas essayer de dupliquer
par contre nous sommes en train de
construire un partenariat avec la CNIL
française avec les autres cnils pour
veiller justement à activer cet accès
des données à pouvoir généraliser cet
API Twitter à toutes les plateformes
pour permettre d'avancer après
vos paroles je vois du petit lait sur
vos paroles ça fait qu'on doit
travailler avec nos partenaires
européens parce qu'on est convaincu que
c'est en travaillant ensemble avec du
parangonnage en allant chercher à
diversité on est très fier avec l'aide
de Sciences Po et de l'Institut mines
Télécom en janvier on a une conférence
internationale à Paris sur l'accès des
chercheurs aux données avec la présence
de la Commission européenne et de la
présidente du régulateur irlandais je
vous cache pas que on cultive notre
relation avec nos amis irlandais parce
que on a une nouvelle gouvernance dans
le DSA qui est plus puissante que celle
du rgpd et qui dit que il y a encore un
rôle pour irrégateur irlandais mais il y
a la Commission européenne en plus qui
lui rentrent avec toute sa puissance
justement pour pour sortir de ce point
de faiblesse qu'on avait avec le
principe du pays de d'origine et de dire
non qu'on s'est très grands acteurs on a
la Commission européenne en plus et tous
les régulateurs viennent c'est sa
présence française qui a obtenu ça dans
le règlement et donc on essaie de le
mettre en avant et on a une dynamique
extrêmement positive parce qu'à la fin
les chercheurs qui vont accéder aux
données
de Tik Tok de Facebook de Google devront
être agréés par le régulateur irlandais
qui pourra s'appuyer sur un prêt
agrément donné par le régulateur
national c'est-à-dire a priori par
l'arcom si c'est l'arcane qui est
désigné comme digital service
coordinateur coordinateur et services
numériques
donc oui c'est un nouveau ça ressemblera
plus à la logique du réseau des Banques
centrales ou c'est vraiment des
capacités institutionnelles dans chaque
pays une capacité institutionnelle au
centre et ça fonctionne comme un réseau
aujourd'hui on vient d'un monde où sur
la lutte contre un manipulation de la
formation vous aviez le travail qui
était fait à l'Union européenne avec le
code de bonne pratique contre la
désinformation et en France vous avez la
recommandation de l'arcom sur le même
sujet et on essaye de faire converger
ces dynamiques en disant mais dorénavant
on a une dynamique européenne et on va
tous participer à vérifier qu'elle est
vraiment mise en oeuvre par les
plateformes dans chacun de nos
géographies et qu'elle est vraiment
pertinente et revenir l'exercice pour
dire on en veut plus ou différemment
dans le cycle suivant
sur le système d'alerte parce qu'on l'a
vu avec farose alors on a eu l'occasion
ça c'est quand même recueil de données
alors il y a beaucoup de déperition et
ça couvre pas tout et quand je suis allé
voir le système d'alerte sur la
désinformation donc au service d'action
extérieur de l'Union européenne j'étais
quand même assez bluffé du niveau et le
fait qu'il y a un lieu de recueillement
de ce signalement aujourd'hui moi je ne
sais pas orienter quelqu'un qui me dit
je suis victur des victimes d'une
censure sur telle ou telle plateforme
alors on a on est en train de construire
la réponse là aussi du dans la logique
du Règlement sur le service numérique
européen cette fonctionnait de faire
fonctionner une série de réseau donc je
représente pas aujourd'hui l'arcom je
représente l'arcom un membre de l'erga
le réseau des régulateurs européens et
demain j'espère l'arcom membre du
conseil des services numériques qui sera
le réseau des DSC
essaye de travailler en réseau au niveau
national
avec Pharos bien évidemment avec le
parquet national numérique sur la haine
en ligne avec virginum qui est un
système de surveillance de l'état et
nous avons commencé à poser les bases il
faut arriver à poser des réseaux avec la
société civile avec le réseau avec le
monde académique pour mobiliser on a
déjà commencé à le faire dans la
précédente élection présidentielle et on
sait qu'il y a un enjeu il faudra le
faire de manière encore plus puissante
de manière plus coordonnée dans les
prochains cycles électoraux parce que
nos sociétés se numérisent toujours plus
le débat public se déplace toujours plus
entre et à cheval entre les médias
éditorialisés et les médias
algorithmiques et donc il faut
progresser à chaque fois pour aller plus
loin pour être capable de réagir on a pu
le voir ceci étant dit dans la campagne
présidentielle la dernière
quelques semaines avant l'élection un
vendredi
Twitter a fermé par erreur une série de
comptes d'une des campagnes électorale
et tout de suite ça a tourné vinaigre
sur Twitter parce que les gens ont vu
leur compte fermer et c'était le premier
rang militant d'un des candidats ça nous
est remonté par trois canaux en l'espace
de très très vite et on s'est retourné
vers Twitter qui savait qu'il savait
qu'il devrait nous rendre compte donc
s'attendait pas à ce qu'on lui dise quoi
faire mais ils savaient qu'il devrait
nous rendre des comptes de comment il
gérait la situation et donc tout de
suite une a dit bah oui j'ai un
algorithme qui a qui a mal tourné et qui
a fermé par erreur ses comptes les mal
paramétré j'ai déjà corrigé et on dit
oui et il dit et oui et je vais
communiquer pour expliquer parce qu'on a
dit vous devez gérer obligation de
diligence et vous devez faire savoir ce
que vous faites et c'est devenu une
péripétie vous avez vous pouvez
retrouver quelques articles dans
quelques journaux qu'on en parlait et
qui en ont rendu compte et c'était notre
objectif d'avoir ce maillage pour que
tout le monde réagisse vite et que c'est
péripéties informationsnel ne à la fin
ne soit pas des incidents dans le
fonctionnement de nos démocraties on a
retenu aussi de la leçon on l'a
mentionné dans notre rapport public
d'abord la scène CCP la commission
électorale a mentionné que la
coopération c'était bien faite avec les
plateformes avec vigilum avec l'arcome
nous-mêmes après dans notre rapport on a
vu on a vu à quel point il faudrait être
vigilant dans le futur à bien insister
auprès de toutes les campagnes des
partis politiques sur le fait que sur
les plateformes toutes les lois s'y
appliquent y compris les lois sur le
copyright et sera protection de de la
propriété intellectuelle parce que on
n'est pas passé loin d'avoir certaines
chaînes de sur les réseaux sociaux qui
soient fermés pour infraction
au droit aux droits moral des auteurs et
ce qui aurait été une péripétie
inutile dans le fonctionnement du jeu
politique donc on voit qu'il en
permanence il faut s'adapter construire
des réseaux mobilisés et pour faire face
à un espace qui est toujours plus
numérique
en même temps quand il y a des candidats
qui eux-mêmes ont des problèmes de droit
d'auteur sur leur clip vous n'êtes pas
aidé non plus monsieur do Suez avait une
question à poser oui merci monsieur le
Président
j'aurais une question un peu plus terre
à terre vous avez pas de moyens
dérisoire de l'arcom pour
pour la régulation mais justement
c'était pour vous faire peut-être
préciser là-dessus j'ai bien compris que
c'était pas vous avez pas un rôle de de
régulateur au sens expert qui allait
chercher directement dans les chez les
plateformes
certaines exigences de en termes de
normes etc c'est plus d'une déclarative
la plateforme mais que vous étiez là
pour mettre la lumière sur sur les
algorithmes sur la façon dont les
plateformes fonctionnent sur la mode de
fonctionnement et laisser les chercheurs
après travailler avec cette matière là
et dans un cercle vertueux améliorer
tout ça
donc moi j'ai des questions bassement
pratique et budgétaire au sein de
l'arcom ça représente combien de
personnes en pourcentage peut-être des
ressources humaines dédiées à cette à ce
travail en lien avec les plateformes ça
représente une part importante est-ce
que ça va progresser est-ce que c'est
amené à progresser
et puis sur ce travail avec les
chercheurs est-ce que l'arcom va être
porteur d'appel à projet
en propre pour exiger des chercheurs ou
demander à de faire la transparence et à
analyser un peu les retours des
plateformes est-ce que vous allez
travailler en tant que porteur de
d'appel à projet et puis
l'arcom c'est la fusion CSA Hadopi donc
vous avez aussi vous l'avez dit un lien
avec les médias que vous appelez
éditorialisés contre les médias
algorithmiques vous êtes faites le lien
l'opposition entre les deux
ce qui nous intéresse un peu aussi dans
cette dans cette commission c'est de
savoir comment ces algorithmes ont en
quelque sorte façonn é le débat polarisé
le débat et donc est-ce que vous
observez une dynamique la même dynamique
de polarisation du débat nous ce qu'on
peut observer aussi mais peut-être que
vous avec votre poste d'observation
c'est plus simple de de lien entre la
façon dont les algorithmes ont accéléré
une forme de polarisation et comment ça
s'est traduit dans les médias
éditorialisés classiques et est-ce que
les deux maintenant fonctionnent de la
même façon avec voilà une polarisation
extrême de tout ça
alors aujourd'hui
on a trois
vous avez une direction des plateformes
en ligne j'ai à ma droite sont directeur
adjoint qui a 8 personnes
mais on a une deuxième équipe qui est
dans nos directions des études qui
portent justement toutes les enjeu
d'accès des chercheurs aux données donc
là on peut encore ajouter une ou deux
personnes sans doute qui travaillent sur
le sujet et puis on a une partie de
l'équipe qui est dans la direction
européenne parce qu'il y a un énorme
enjeu comme de travail en réseau et on
tous ces groupes convergent dans ce
qu'on appelle dans le vocabulaire de
l'arcom qui hérité de qui vient de son
héritage et ça dans un groupe de travail
que je préside c'est à ce titre que vous
m'avez invité à venir quel groupe de
travail supervision des plateformes en
ligne ou on fait on veille à la
coordination à faire avancer ça
c'est ces équipes se sont pas
suffisantes elles ont vocation à grossir
et le budget qui a été adopté par le
Parlement pour l'année 2023 pour l'arcom
permet de faire une montée en puissance
elle devra s'étaler sur plusieurs années
toujours un peu de temps pour faire les
montées en puissance le
il faut avoir une taille critique il
faut avoir une taille critique notamment
pour être capable de mener certains
travaux avec nous y compris pour être
crédible pour animer ce réseau de avec
la recherche extérieure et comprendre
leurs problématiques mais il ne faut pas
vouloir les contrôler
la force du monde de la recherche chez
sa décentralisation c'est le fait que il
se pose leur propre question et que on
ne sait jamais où on décrète
l'innovation et c'est ça cette force on
se voit un peu comme
avoir un rôle de d'animateur de vraiment
de leur mettre le pied à l'étrier pour
qu'il voit tout le potentiel du texte
européen mais je pense que
je me permets de faire aujourd'hui un
appel à la représentation nationale au
gouvernement pour que y ait des budgets
qui soient mis en place des programmes
d'agence nationale de la recherche pour
aller sur ces sciences sociales et des
sciences du numérique et sur les
programmes interdisciplinaires vu
l'enjeu de ces médias du rôle qui
prennent de on vit dans un monde
numérique et en partie
que j'ai été directeur général de larsem
j'ai travaillé au déploiement de la
fibre optique au développement des
réseaux mobiles on a un peu trop réussi
on pourrait dire c'est à dire que la
vitesse à laquelle on est tous dans un
monde où on a tous un smartphone une
capacité à aller chercher de
l'information a été plus vite que le
développement de nos compétences de nos
citoyenneté numérique de ce sentiment de
responsabilité et il faut arriver à
rattraper tout ça donc on a aussi des
réseaux à développer qui sont des
réseaux territoriaux et c'est
extrêmement important on a la chance à
l'arcom d'avoir des arcs comme locaux
avec dans chaque région un Arcome local
avec des gens qui qui sont engagés qui
aujourd'hui historiquement travaillaient
à mettre en oeuvre la régulation des
radios locales principalement et un
petit peu des télévisions locales mais
qui de plus en plus on est à réfléchir
on a commencé comment les s'en servir
comme étant des activateurs pour
descendre et amener les outils qu'on va
construire au niveau européen pour
examener dans toutes nos géographies si
je prends exemple du harcèlement
scolaire on va peut-être trouver grâce à
cette mécanique dire il y a un risque
systémique là-dessus qui appelle des
réponses la construction d'outils par
chaque plateforme et la question va être
de dire mais très bien mais quand on l'a
ramené à l'arcom à Paris on n'a rien
fait
comment on descend un cran plus loin et
donc on a commencé à faire des premières
pages pour voir comment est-ce qu'on
travaille avec les collectivités
territoriales les élus locaux ou et on a
une première tour en disant elle s'en
revoit formation des élus
des et une approche où on laisse les
territoires se réapproprier le sujet
numérique dans la globalité parce
qu'effectivement
la démarche est plus globale ça va de la
cybersécurité jusque à la citoyenneté
numérique et on est en train de
réfléchir comment là aussi on passe à
une échelle systémique nous-mêmes
et créer des nouvelles dynamiques
ça me demandera quelques moyens
effectivement on aura l'occasion de
revenir alors vraiment toute petite
parce que je voulais que monsieur le
rapporteur puisse terminer les questions
qui lui restaient qu'on puisse conclure
c'est la question qui m'était signalée
par un autre collègue qui mène une
mission sur la musique qui me disait que
Tik Tok ne payait pas les taxes sur les
services vidéo et la taxe sur le
numérique alors que les gafams cela
quittent alors je sais pas si c'est du
ressort de la com mais quel type de
sanction parce que quand on a vous
pouvez interdire ou en tous les cas
résilier un contrat de diffusion pour
une chaîne pour une radio quel type de
sanction vous avez par ailleurs
vis-à-vis d'un service comme celui-ci
qui ne qui ne respecte pas ses
obligations minimales
alors le pas sûr de pouvoir répondre
précisément juridiquement sur le sujet
mais l'arcom vous le savez est aussi
l'héritière de la dopie donc on est on a
un mandat spécifique sur le sujet et
donc on sera toujours à disposition
disponible ne serait-ce que pour faire
un premier exercice de médiation et de
mettre les gens une tour d'une table et
de faire avancer le sujet sinon vous me
votre question me permet de le rappeler
le pouvoir de sanctionner des
plateformes comme Tik Tok dans le
l'architecture du Règlement sur les
services numériques toutes les
plateformes en fait est réparties entre
la Commission européenne et les
régulateurs des différents États membres
donc pour un non respect du régime le
plus important celui des ristysémiques
que j'ai mentionné pour les grandes
plateformes en ligne c'est la Commission
européenne qui porte ce pouvoir donc ça
et elle a prouvé qu'elle savait mettre
des amendes record sans état d'âme ou
très grande plateforme américaine
voilà et pour les plateformes de moindre
envergure ou pour les obligations
simples ça repose sur le régulateur du
pays ou la plateforme à installer donc
typiquement
le régulateur des services numériques le
coordinateur et services numériques
français sera doté par la loi d'un poids
de sanction qui pourrait exercer auprès
des acteurs qui seraient installés en
France y compris à la demande des autres
régulateurs donc c'est aussi un point
quel jour arriver c'est-à-dire que on a
on va avoir un rôle d'être
alors
la mécanique du la mécanique du
règlement socialiste numérique justement
essaie de clarer de faciliter ça et mais
bien en place un réseau de régulateur et
donc quand vous serez une association en
France qui sera très je garde cette
image toujours de lutte contre l'obésidé
l'obésité motivé en disant mais il y a
une réalité ça n'est pas mis en oeuvre
elle pourra se retourner vers le
régulateur français qui transmettra au
régulateur irlandais et ça deviendra
directement une relation entre
régulateurs de dire je vous transmets la
plainte à vous de la gérer il reste
proprement nous on pourra recevoir des
plaintes sachant que vous savez qu'on a
une plateforme en France qui est peu
connue en France qui s'appelle yubo qui
a un réseau social mais qui a un très
gros succès dans les pays anglo-saxons
et qui parfois pose des soucis un pays
anglo-saxon et donc on s'attend à ce que
nous aussi on recevra du coup des
demandes de l'Irlande et peut-être
extra-européenne pour aller sur le sujet
donc il y a vraiment cette logique de
fonctionnement en réseau et de
mobilisation pour
qui a été vraiment va un niveau
supérieur et on a tiré les conséquences
et l'expérience du rgpd pour avoir une
efficacité renforcée
merci bien monsieur le rapporteur
merci beaucoup je crois qu'on a approche
du terme de cette
réunion
je voudrais vous poser deux questions
la première qui est une question que je
vous avais posée tout à l'heure et ne
concerne pas les données mais vous
n'avez pas répondu et je vous disais
justement que c'est une question qui
intéresse beaucoup plusieurs membres de
la commission c'est la question de l'âge
alors la question là c'est une caisse
est une vaste question et le consomme
pas que TiK ToK on a bien suivi les
épisodes un peu malheureux pour la recom
de la plainte contre les
contre les sites pornographiques dans
laquelle vous n'avez pas eu satisfaction
éventuellement peut-être je voudrais
vous demander si le le le chemin
juridique suit son cours de ce point de
vue là ou s'il est terminé mais c'est
pas la question évidemment de
d'aujourd'hui pour Tik Tok c'est une
autre question
elle est bien entendu en rapport
puisqu'il s'agit des mesures de contrôle
de l'âge est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire aujourd'hui parce qu'il paraît
évident les associations de parents nous
le disent que les enfants de 8 ans
passent leur nuit enfin que des enfants
de 8 ans passent leur nuit sur Tik Tok
etc est-ce que dans la réunion du 13
mars vous avez eu de ce point-là vous
avez évoqué le sujet et est-ce que vous
avez eu des explications ou des
engagements de la part de Tik Tok et
puis le deuxième question elle vient de
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure on a
bien compris l'importance des API et de
la nécessité des API pour lancer le
débat à l'échelle de l'ensemble du
public et pas seulement à l'échelle des
spécialistes est-ce que cette question a
été abordée dans la réunion du 13 mars
est-ce que Tik Tok a pris des
engagements
et sinon est-ce que
l'application du DSA est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner un calendrier qu'il
existe peut-être il est peut-être public
mais je ne l'ai pas en tête un
calendrier de l'application du DSA en
France et notamment sur ce sujet là
l'application quand ça deviendra une
contrainte
juridiquement la question entre
plateforme et médias on voit justement
et c'est tout l'intérêt de ces saisir de
ce sujet de régulation des plateformes
de médias algorithmiques à l'arcome qui
s'occupe de médias audiovisuels que on a
un seul espace informationnel dans
lequel nos sociétés fonctionnent
l'opinion publique se forme la formation
au sens et on a deux moteurs les médias
éditorialisés et les médias
algorithmiques et l'arcom effectivement
encore hier j'étais avec ma collègue
Bénédicte Lesage qui est préside un
groupe de travail elle sera santé
publique et je suis sans vice-président
et on travaille justement sur ce
problème de
des chartes alimentaires
qu'on demande aux médias audiovisuel de
souscrire dans lequel on demande d'agir
de manière plus responsable et on
souhaite potentiellement qui s'en fasse
plus et effectivement dans le dialogue
avec eux ils nous disent mais vous nous
en demandez beaucoup et vous demandez
rien aux plateformes numériques et on
voit que là aussi on va pouvoir je me
projette dans le futur mais c'est dans
le règlement sur le service numérique et
notre avenir on va pouvoir dire mais on
a identifié un riz systémique vous avez
pris des engagements et qu'on va pouvoir
du coup aborder parce que on a eu des
données on a des données qui ont été
préparées par nos équipes et qui montre
à quel point la durée d'écoute
individuelle baisse ton anciennement sur
les médias audiovisuels mais encore plus
fortement sur les jeunes or on est comme
vous on pense que nos jeunes hélas se
passent toujours plus de temps sur les
écrans et donc s'il est passe par garde
à la télévision c'est bien qu'il regarde
autre chose et donc il faut bien avoir
une approche globale et que on va
pouvoir justement avoir des approches
intégrées et les équipes de l'arcom qui
travaillent sur ces jeux transvers de
cohésion sociale vont pouvoir dans le
futur on est justement on est travaillé
sur les deux Pan s des deux familles de
médias pour avoir une meilleure
efficacité
sur le sujet de l'âge
ça n'est pas le plus simple et
aujourd'hui d'un point de juridique on
n'est pas armé on a rien pour le sujet
on est comme vous on doit constater que
effectivement les limites d'âge ne sont
pas respectées
c'est aussi vieux comme le monde dans le
monde réel non plus
mais l'objectif reste pertinent
mais vous la demande pas toujours mais
mais il faut avancer il faut avancer
on aura là aussi là il est clair que de
notre point de vue et il est évident
qu'il va falloir identifier un risque
systémique sur toute cette plateforme
qui est la mise en danger des mineurs et
que ça va nous permettre d'avoir le
support juridique pour revenir en disant
donc le statu quo encore une fois n'est
pas possible que proposez-vous mais tous
ces sujets sont il
n'y a pas de solution merveilleuse parce
qu'il y a pas de miracle si on veut
mieux caractériser l'âge des jeunes ça
veut dire qu'on va mieux caractériser
l'âge des adultes aussi donc c'est une
face c'est une pièce à deux faces donc
on va buter sur d'autres difficultés
mais ça doit avoir lieu et il faut
progresser c'est il est clair que ça
n'est pas raisonnable on ne peut pas
laisser filer comme ça l'usage nous on
est extrêmement convaincu et là aussi on
réfléchit
souvent des solutions peuvent exister et
la question est souvent la question de
comment réussir la généralisation la
montée en puissance et donc il y a un
enjeu effectivement de communication et
donc de parfois de demander aux médias
audiovisuel de nous aider pour faire
savoir
sur 98% des terminaux utilisent deux
systèmes d'exploitation
iOS d'Apple et Android de Google sur ces
deux systèmes exploitations vous avez
des systèmes de contrôle parentaux au
sens large extrêmement sophistiqué avec
une
ergonomique avait des progrès
phénoménaux mais qui sont peu employés
et donc le premier enjeu c'est sans
doute de mobiliser de susciter l'usage
et donc de travailler avec des réseaux
de parents d'associations de parents
d'élèves de collectivités territoriales
pour provoquer l'adhésion et utiliser on
là aussi
on a beaucoup de dispositifs et à un
moment où il faut
il faut aller chercher la culture
américaine qu'une culture la culture
européenne est excellente à concevoir
des systèmes puissants la culture
américaine soit meilleure à livrer le
résultat et là il faut se retrousser les
manches et foufou faut dire il y a
beaucoup de choses qui sont sur étagères
et qu'on peut mobiliser
je vous remercie d'abord pour l'exposer
les questions je pense que c'était
extrêmement intéressant pour tout le
monde je vous remercie dans un domaine
où ça doit pas être simple tous les
jours de pratiquer aussi peu l'anglise
vraiment de ce point de vue là vous êtes
épatant monsieur donc on a parlé on a
parlé de parents gonage on a parlé de
coordinateur service numérique c'est
extraordinaire voilà je vous remet un
badge comme on fait sur les réseaux
sociaux merci monsieur le Président
merci infiniment et bien évidemment le
les questionnaires qui vous ont été
adressés c'est dans le cadre de la
commission mensuelle que les réponses
sont soumises au même disposition ce qui
vous permettra de préciser peut-être ce
qu'on a pas eu le temps d'évoquer merci
beaucoup messieurs merci beaucoup bonne
journée à toutes et à tous